[Music]
one of the joys of writing comics is the
hope that someone will take that story
and make it something their own
and i think the folks at warner brothers
have done a tremendous job translating
and evolving the quarter vowels into the
game the fans they cosplays these
characters they're hungry for more and
so here you are getting to play out that
that conflict in a game itself
[Music]
i remember taking this walk around new
york city to my old neighborhood nothing
i knew was there anymore all of the
people i had known had moved away um all
of the stores were gone the feeling was
so unsettling and i wanted to craft a
story that would make bruce wayne feel
the way i felt the first time i read
that story i was just blown away because
they were creating this really rich
secret history of gotham city very
plausible believable that was in direct
opposition to batman i think probably
inspiration uh for the court of owls
originates from nature just by the real
fact that the owl is a natural predator
to the bat what an owl does a lot of the
time is it hunts you and it stalks you
without you seeing it and the fun of the
way that the court goes after bruce is
to watch him from afar for years because
it's been something that's been in
gotham for so long and been so powerful
and right beneath batman's nose i think
that's the the root of the success there
[Music]
one of the biggest challenges with
bringing the court of owls from comic
books to video games is really the
interactive nature of what video games
are how do you take that history how do
you take this cool imagery and bring it
to life in a game that's very satisfying
we could look at the source material we
could talk to the creators and we could
ask their opinions about that we could
say which of these elements do you think
we can translate when i went out there
to see what they were doing with the
game i was blown away i mean it took
what we had done with court of owls but
it just elevated it beyond a lot of the
borders that we had had you can't really
rely on what you think you know about
the court we have expanded we have added
to it
there are different varieties of talons
in gotham nights
and as the players begin to understand
through gameplay the unique strengths
and vulnerability of the talent it will
affect how they equip themselves and how
they unlock new abilities so like any
good rpg we're presenting you with a
problem and then we're presenting you
with a range of potential solutions and
players will have an opportunity to kind
of maximize that according to their own
style
the entire team has worked so hard on
this and put so much love and dedication
into this and i really hope it comes
through and it gives them a really
enjoyable experience i can't wait for us
to share more information about this
game but watch out for those deadly
talents because they are sharp
be careful
[Music]
[Music]
you